let's just begin by reviewing okay
firstly what do i mean by standard
instrument i hope by now
you've seen that during the hsc you get
um
generally on the back of your two unit
and extension one before your pictures
excuse me a little table and all it's
got is maybe 10 or 12
integrals that you're so expected to
know but they give them to you
for free okay so things like uh let's
see
the integral of x to the m with respect
to x is equal to
you can give it to me this is
integrating right so what do i do
okay okay good power goes up
and then you divide by the new power
right plus you're constant with one
exception
what's the exception to this rule
m cannot be now why would
would that be the case why can't it be
that
right okay because if you have one over
x here
right you don't use this rule at all the
integral of one
on x is log x isn't it we've just been
looking at that okay
so anyway you've got these there's a few
there but really you shouldn't need to
look at the table standard page okay
because these are the kinds of ones
which you've been doing for a long time
what we're talking about is the issues
that don't belong there okay
so for instance we know this
right this is a simple one it's on the
actually if i
chuck an a in there um you do know
that's on the table standing
just quickly just like before what is
the integral equal to
there's some division happening isn't
there because
when we differentiate go the other way
right
chain rule tells you you have to
multiply by the of that inside function
which is a
the one on a cancels out and that's what
you end up with okay
plus your constant okay but we've looked
at yesterday how you might approach a
question like this
okay this is the specific example we
used actually it's not a standard
integral
how did we do it what trick did we use
to get
this value
now you got two sort of approaches right
i i think sort of the trickier one is
the one that the textbook uses
the textbook says look two you can
express that as
base e with some other stuff at the
index how do we express two do you
remember
e to the power of log two so that's two
right and then you go to the power of x
and then off you go
okay but the other method of doing it
is to remember that to the x we actually
know a fair bit about 2dx
right we know that if we started with 2
to the x
as our primitive right if you
differentiate
then you get a very familiar result do
you remember what it was
2 to the x we sort of developed that
result by limits yeah
okay now excuse me do you remember what
we did from this point you said well
okay
if you differentiate this you get here
if you integrate this you ought to be
able to go back okay so all you need to
do is
shuffle around a little bit in this case
divide by log 2
and that will get you what you want on
the right hand side now i can just
integrate everything with respect to
x and that gave us
over here that gave us our result
1 over log 2
2 to the x plus your constant okay so
this idea here this is what i'm trying
to go after
that you can mean an integral that you
you don't know how to integrate it it
isn't
part of the things you're expected to
know okay but you can use this
differentiation trick
to get something similar enough that you
can work it out this happens all the
time okay
so as well as being called non-state
integrals these are often
named differentiate
hence integrate that's that's kind of
the name of the question you there
follow a very specific pattern of the
hsc okay
so let me give you a classic example
it's in 13 c
okay and if you haven't done this
already you want to do this example now
differentiate
x e to the x okay and then i think they
say
uh hence integrate
x that's the question okay
who's done it already yeah good
excellent
about halfway right so for those of you
just make sure you're setting out okay
on this for the rest of you
how would you go about this now the
reason why they have to give you this
clue
is because actually the x is a product
right and we don't really have a um
we've got a product rule we're changing
we've got reverse channel
we don't really have reverse product
rules do we okay hence the need for this
kind of trick
yeah so let's give this a go let's
follow their steps so they've said
differentiate x
e to the x right it's just a product
u there v there what are you gonna write
x
wow this is a much simpler derivative
than i thought it was okay
hold on how does protocol go your u v
dash
right so in this case v dash is just
okay good right so there's one half
what's the other half
plus one times
okay good that's u dash v
fantastic okay let's just tidy that up a
little bit
okay now i'm going to keep that left
hand side there
because i walked you through this step
over here of how i rearrange okay
what am i after i'm after the integral
of this
okay so in a second i'm going to
integrate everything with respect to x
okay but before i do that i want to do a
bit of rearranging i want to get this
guy
on its own so what should i do okay so
i'll subtract this e to the x okay
uh at the same time since i want the
integral of this to be the subject i
might as well move that over here so
i'll do that
okay now being that i've just integrated
okay i have to integrate everything else
as well
okay so when i integrate this what
should i expect to get
just x edx i just go back where i came
from
right plus a constant yes
okay now hold on a second what did i do
i moved
this guy over here so he's actually a
negative now right
and i have to integrate it okay is that
all right
now by the way no no mark is going to
lose sleep over this you shouldn't
either
but in a second i'm going to have
another constant flying around okay
so for now i'm going to say this c
when i introduce that i really ought to
say what is it it's an arbitrary real
number
okay so that's why i like this on the
side
now i can integrate this thing on the
left hand side i don't need to integrate
because that's the question
yeah so i'll just leave there
that's already accounted for that's fine
what's this
it's just in the accident
now most of you 95 percent of you will
just leave that as c
okay it's just sort of okay because it's
still an arbitrary constant
the thing is you have a top class higher
standards okay
these two constants they may be the same
but more than likely they're not okay so
really we ought to call it something
else
yeah now like i said no one's gonna lose
any sleep over that i doubt you'd
lose any marks but it's not right to
have the same constant appearance just
like i'm just gonna lump them in
together whatever
how discriminatory are you they're real
numbers
don't get it feel them anyway all right
so do you see
what i did um you start off with the
clue they give you
but you need to do some shuffling before
you can get to what you want
okay all right